one country Oh what is going on YouTube
for those of you who have not seen this
video
ah [ __ ] we're back at it again aren't we
this is racism and its best basically
it's about a woman who's on the [ __ ]
and she goes around just spouting out
saying that minorities are taking over
these big Rowan bring [ __ ] Britain
watch out color people are coming in
usually there's a part of this video
that's absolutely pathetic I need you
check this part out I collect me a
little bit you know why this part
cracked me up because I already knew
where she was baby when she said it
bollocks I'm good tell him to go back
where they came from is it were they
from a city where there's a black people
as Edward and when we admit [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] go back to the Kurama
you do G minorities [ __ ] yo get
minority I want you to take a good hard
look at all the color people around the
world and look at the percentage and the
numbers go because we are everywhere
percentage populations of so-called
ethnic minorities crowds mother college
burn trance on your numbers son which
means we are popping up babies non-stop
mother UK is not bus that's right yes
skank asaurus the kamasutra wasn't made
for no reason you girl what I'm saying
you know what the best way to threaten a
racist person is tell them that you'll
have a baby and raise yours to hunt
bears that's right you keep it up I'll
give you a little winery a grandchild
and get my other hobbies to do your
other kids make your family porch you
look like the muck
you went [ __ ]
being British is not an ethnicity I
cannot reiterate this if you gonna be a
racist you might as well be the best
races you could be tell a black people
they're from Nicaragua and then she's
not British what the hell is wrong with
you you know I'm disappointed is because
you're the sorriest racist out there
tell you something diversity is a
blessing you know what because it
teaches people tolerance and how to be
human beings but you just want why
people everywhere what you want vanilla
for the rest of your life based on open
chocolate chips and ice cream then
people as woman I bet you hate rocky
road too huh
cuz a whole bunch of chocolate ice cream
with a little white marshmallow stuck in
it huh
that's that how you feel is that how you
feel a bit you feel like the rocky road
that's kind of you know I'm angry like
this little pimple on my chin if I'll
ever see you ask the UK imma grab you
and bring you back over the United
States and leave in the middle of
Compton then you see how race you want
to be go back to Nicaragua you black
people [ __ ] the [ __ ] you just say uh-uh
me I didn't say anything I'm just gonna
go okay
well if you all written it out there I
want to kill myself how and what the
hell is this how you gonna be cursing
the funny yet baby [ __ ] with that baby's
blood their money me show y'all even
don't curse this funny babies and I'm a
piece of [ __ ]
which makes you uh something I can come
from this you below [ __ ] anyway I know
that all of us are so shocked that this
lady could say something like this but
let's be honest for a second she is not
unique she's a dime a dozen people like
her really do exist in this world and
it's a very sad thing so Big Ups to the
brothers and sisters on the train to
chose to beat a boss about the situation
and not choked the [ __ ] out y'all shows
a lot of decency restraint in class
which honestly speaks better for me cuz
might get a laugh with her you know I
wanna [ __ ] I woulda [ __ ] you know no I
wouldn't have [ __ ] I would have I did it
again
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] bring a culture oh [ __ ] what the
purse to find the country it was the
best way to threaten a racist person is
you have a baby and then you race
there's a blogger philosopher good lord
intense I know
[Music]